all right maria
maria where'd you grow up where are you
from originally i'm from
l.a uh south central south central yeah
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents growing up no just one
just mom
just one my mom my mom from from when i
was born from up to um seven
and with her she used to uh reason why
i got taking from her is because she's
been about to win multiple men's and
having sex
um she um get high next to the bed next
to me
um she was go say she's going to grocery
store and she's coming back we've been
gone for a week
and it was um it was i was seven and my
brother was five she was in there for
like days so one had particularly
one particular day my grandma just
happened to come by and she wasn't there
and i opened the door and she took us
from there
um for us birthdays and stuff she would
take us shopping to buy birthday gifts
and buy them and then we would come home
from school they were all gone
and then the man that she would uh be
date um seeing uh
actually two of them raped me um when i
was like more
let's say more in middle school and then
more high school
and then like as i got older too as well
uh
it was a one mexican who said it one
hispanic guy and one
one was black it was like long beach and
i think
long beach and laundry in compton um he
had raped me
and i told her and she didn't believe me
and so from there
there was just multiple abuses and then
i
went from group homes multiple group
homes and from the group homes when i
left from there
i got out and i had one son and one son
and then
um with her jealousy and her controlling
he ended up getting taken from me not
knowing how to be a mother as well
when they took him and as a friend said
hey let's go you do dance pretty well
let's try you go from different state to
state so i tried it
i went from saint louis no that's where
they kept me hostage in st louis
i went from arizona and from arizona to
new york and then we got to um
saint louis so you were traveling around
as a is it stripper oh it's supposed to
be dancing you know young minded not
knowing
what do you say when you say dancing
what do you mean i was stripping dancing
okay at 23 i'm back i'm not knowing why
so i go
and when i get there it was like an
apartment
and you know they kept me barricaded
inside the back room
and um cutting up dress whatever they
were doing and um
i asked i just got them frustrated i was
there like over the two months
and i happened to just come out to the
restroom and see
a address and they had herself my home
phone there and i called
and just told them that i was there and
they came by
and it came by one particular day for
some reason it must been god
they came by and they had just left and
it came by and opened the door and they
took me
and put me back on the train i got back
here when i got back here i got the adam
figueroa
central central imperial figure of
pre-op award and uh they said we wanted
to hit the primo i said sure and i
should have tried it
and from smoking the primo it would
start making me throw up it didn't
change really set up real feelings then
i started then she said just trying to
pipe it more better
so i tried it and from there i kind of
got into it so being homeless
i stayed in a basement um
on a bus stop a train i stayed on
in someone's building and um in the top
top floor always go to the top floor
where they have like was
different levels i went all the way to
the fifth floor
i stayed up in the top row up there and
laid there for a while
went to a tent um kind of like
not used to it but stayed in the tent
where
roaches crawled around the line it
rained it had holes and i woke up with
all kind of wet clothes and then then
i um back um back back grab my seizures
and i woke up and the guy had already
took my clothes off and
he was trying to insert his penis inside
me and then kind of like pushed him off
and whatever and he said he was like
just sharing so i pushed him off
was able to get away from that then went
back to imperial figaro
standing right there trying to figure
out how i was going to survive
i actually didn't get in the car with a
man and
um he said he'll take me and pay me
i was a the bronco bronco motel
went there and um he um said he's gonna
pay me
and he said you want to see where that
stuff well and then after he did that
he turned around pushed me down hit me
by the back of my neck and it
ripped me in from the from behind and at
my my butt and after there i just been
on the streets homeless as far as hungry
i would go in the store and act like i'm
buying something and grab it and go sit
in the restroom and eat
um if i saw something sent by a trash
can i would just eat it if i saw
somebody stop sitting down there
pick it up and eat it and stuff like
that and so
um as going on and on and on
shower bathing was very very hard didn't
have anywhere to bait taking the shower
and nothing like that didn't have any
clothes and then the man the man's down
here
say oh wait you know i got a place where
he is cool and then it didn't turn out
to be what they said and they said would
you like a cigarette or something to
drink
and i drinked it and i wasn't able to
walk when i woke up
i was on a sidewalk with um just an
empty purse laying on the sidewalk um
just
over my belongings and um i had some
semen all between my legs
and from that point on i just
i couldn't do it no more so here i would
go
travel all the way to alameda where the
fashion district
and go right behind the trash can and
lay behind there and sleep
but then i learned that it was
transvestites over there homosexuals
but they pretty much didn't bother me
but they had jumped men come through
there to smoke crystal
and then one guy was trying to talk to
me and uh didn't want to talk to him
that was very scarce and they
started burning me with a pipe i burnt
like bruises on there
and so i'm just in the corner from there
so from that point on it was just like
very well it was nowhere to turn to as
like as that
as the same as now but i'm trying to
find myself but it's really hard when
you don't have anybody
and to help it's like they say they
don't they'll help you they help you
just okay let me get into contact with
my boss
and it's like really really not that and
when you're asking for help and they say
okay well we'll get back to you we'll
get back to you get back to you
um somebody burned down the ten and a
half i don't have no clothes
no food so on a daily basis eating food
i just
see if i hear people come with food if
they don't come by with food
i would just ask and ask if not if i saw
something
man that's too much i would eat it but i
was you know because i was super hungry
and um those pretty pies and then
urinated using restroom there sometimes
i would just stand there
all night praying that nobody would
bother me because it was cold i was
hungry
but no shoes on no underwear on you know
how i feel now i want to take a shower
so bad
and eat something and i don't have it
and it's just it's for discomfort
and then the the man right here say look
you want to come with me
you're going to cover me i'll give you
five dollars and all this stuff
i'm just like really scared uh man now
uh
you know you know the bruise right here
you guys told me to come with him he
busted me in the head right here just
busted wide open my hair
and it kind of like just kind of like
healing now
and then from here my shoulder i'm
shooting like my shoulder out of place
and to put my arm losing my vision by
going with
one of them and believing what they're
saying and it gets you inside that a
tent
and then it'll start hurting you know
beating you from that point on so
it's right now for me it's not like uh
it's like i don't have anyone
how long you've been living on the
street uh since i was
19. and how do you know i'm 44.
and you have one child yeah and where's
where's your son
he is not with me he's some way you know
we say inglewood and i
would love to speak with him and talk to
him and the crazy thing about it is um
i go i want to just have to win on
facebook to just to see
how he's doing he's now 27. and
he's a beautiful young man but uh i
don't know how to approach him because
he's been gone since he was four months
for me and so i don't
know how to approach him i just speak to
him but
i don't i'm not saying i feel bad i
don't i want to talk to him but i don't
because i want to come to i want to talk
to him as
you know a normal civilized person but i
just don't think
that um being like this is civilized to
to approach him and i don't want to
bring no
more pain to him and trauma in his life
by coming into him
that situation or rather come to him and
explain to him
everything i did to him when i missed
the best
amount being young in a better way but
coming to him like this
doesn't make it no better you know
because ever since
when it happened to him he was gone
trying to different drugs
i just seemed to um uh was leaning
towards it leaning towards the drug but
it was not really reports to drug
because it really drug if you realize
that the drugs have nothing to do with
it some people say
the drug got them down not to drill down
but technically it's
mental mental thing mentally things
probably in the mind
that it's like really going on you can
you can get sober
but those things like they hunt you like
i give
i give you a hundred hundred deer and
you hunt for deer
and that's just something you do every
season well mine's just like
i've been going i've been doing often on
thing
and it's like you could talk to someone
but it's like it doesn't solve the
problem because it's like
it hits you hard it hits you really
really hard because coming from
a background as a having a family that
was
uh that's not like bad and then
coming from a mother and seeing i
i'm watching watching her do all the
things that i see here
you would think i knew better to to just
go down this path
because i'm watching when her you would
think
hey that's the example right there hey
you don't want to choose that patch you
see what it does to your mom
and it's like no i'm doing it so it
didn't
it's like really sad and then when when
this [ __ ] my mom
didn't get last year she someone told
her that i was down here and she
got on facebook and tried to talk to me
and come reveal me
i don't want to talk to her because you
chose you chose man over me
you know all these things and then you
come about come back be with you
and it's like it's just scary when it's
really very scary when you don't trust
your own
mom and so
i'd rather until i feel like in my own
i'd rather be behind the trash and sleep
somewhere where i know somebody's not
gonna hurt me
but now over here
it's like now it's it's getting beyond
that point now you
you can't really like lay somewhere and
sleep anywhere because
you know i woke up on the sidewalk last
week
i was on fourth to los angeles laying
down and i woke up
and it was in the daytime and woke up
and this man was on
on top of me but i was laying flat and
he jumped on him from behind
and started kissing me and i'm screaming
hey get off me hey get off me and people
just kept walking past
walking past walking past like they
didn't see me screaming at him telling
me hey get that off me and
then he goes oh sorry i thought you was
my wife and kept laughing
and then and it's like in a broad
daylight
this is not night your businesses are
open people walking past
and it's like you don't exist and then
and then i see the same man again four
or five days ago walked past me
and just kept smiling and then i just
went
and had a little hood on me and i
crossed over and went on
opposite side of the street
and so now it's like what do you what do
i do for now what
honestly what do i do what is the
hardest part for you right now is it
just a lack of hope hope it's
courage self-esteem because
i don't believe in myself anymore i
once upon a time i did believe in myself
but now i don't believe myself
i don't like myself uh you know i don't
feel
like attractive a woman i don't i don't
i feel that this small
no now it's like man it's beyond that
point
and if you don't i guess i don't believe
in myself or no courage no hope
i don't think i'm gonna make it
but i wish i wish i could
but i feel like um i feel like
they're going to do the same thing that
have been done for me from childhood
from here
into a different state and you know that
it's just
i'm just very scared do you have any
friends
the friends that i thought were my
friends no
they're not my friends because when you
go to them they say oh my boyfriend's
here
or i'm doing this but a real ashley
friend
i don't know what that's like to have a
friend never had that one only one was
my brother and he said he's in heaven
and he was he was young and we're
growing up so
consider the friend no
just like just like the gentleman that's
sitting around outside right here
um see they think i don't know
but i know and i know what they do to
other people
when they stay around and stuff like
that sitting around when this place
i guess is not open they stand outside
you know humiliating
intimidating women pushing up on women
with youth people
i i see all that that's why i keep my
distance
and then like exactly what you brought
me you say you're gonna be okay you're
gonna be okay
right now i don't even trust them out
there
what is your drug today what what drug
are you using
uh i was using crack cocaine and i tried
some
crystal of some sherm and you say
why are you trying it it's just um i
feel um
i wanted to die i wanted to be here so i
was like well
i don't i'm not i don't have the courage
to kill myself
i said i want to commit suicide i can't
commit suicide because
i don't have the courage to just
actually do it
so you take a drug they'll take you out
i now learn
that two friends i mean well they're not
friends but young ladies they used to
speak to me they're dead
one night in the tent it was then there
for two days
when there were men and other went to
the hotel with a gentleman
and she got her throat slash so that's
that's that
i'm guessing this is eye opener i'm not
sure i want to say because it's a
we're all down the pain same road so i'm
guessing that's what it is
because all that by him and i don't
understand downtown
la they say they're here to help you but
they watch you get beat
they watch you get raped they watch you
and just keep going and just keep
going and all the time you actually get
help
if you flag them down but they feel like
you're on drugs and you're down here so
it's just a drug situation oh she's just
higher or they higher so nothing
and they literally keep going because
when that guy
did that to me you know i waited and
fighting now he said
what was he on drugs or was he like this
well well we'll
keep up and drive around and see and we
can find him it was like
oh like you know like brush up to the
side like whatever but literally it
wasn't it was on
a street called omart and fourth and he
and they did it and
all and there was people standing right
there
and you know and it's like most people
say hey you know stop
we were like well what happened and then
after
i was laying with my nose bleeding and
right there and i couldn't see
didn't go and walk over and said are you
okay
so the often aren't directing but it's
it's it's not
it's not the drug thing it's more
hearing
your life and then surviving
making them hungry thirsty
how are you supporting yourself now so
until i
i was around here moving around i used
to be
i was still trying to prostitute but i
can't i don't even i can't prostitute
because when you get with someone it's
not what they say
or they say that and they may hand you
some money
and turn around and rape you and beat
you and take it back from you
and then you go then you went back all
over
today and it's like every day you gotta
figure out
how you're gonna eat and drink water and
so
mostly because people have this the best
place in the tent
say hey hey she didn't know my name she
said she'll come and say hey lady lady
you want some water you want something
to drink
i said yeah then but when it went to use
the use resume
you know party party come back someone
was on crystal they burnt down the tent
that the lady had gave me
so now i'm basically uh one blanket and
i'm laying on the side
on the corner but i won't lay over here
like i go way past pass past the
greyhound station
all pass um past mateo
oh we're going to go up by uh l.a river
under there
make sure nobody's around let's just sit
there for a couple hours to make sure
us you know and then i'll lay there and
fall asleep
and then to figure out how to take a
shower it's like it's not going to
happen
and so now that this corona thing here
is now it's
like triple heart you can't bathe you
have panties
you know it's you know it's hard it's
it's really really hard
to walk around and you used to be able
to go to mission say are you raising
food here
and i was like you know we're not
serving at a certain time or if you
don't have a mass on you can't come in
and eat
you know i don't have
a mess or anything so i'm standing under
like them want something to eat but i'm
not going to stand around because
all the commotion is going on and um
like
my hair this is healing here starting to
get right here
as i say was being beat like that my
legs still swallow the ankles but it's
getting all better
but you know it's like it's like first
you're gonna do this and then
but yeah it's hard
yeah sounds terrible very hard
what's what's the worst thing that's
happened to you down here
you've been down here a long time yeah
oh being raped
being raped by broad daylight and
and it's not your person your money back
and people stand around and just keep
passing by and hear you scream
and you don't know if you're gonna make
it that's and
it kind of had me still trying to talk a
little bit
i don't know and after after that um
being drugged after after going through
this healing and say stop his head get
your cigarette short
and it's not a cigarette and i can't
walk
and then the man keep pulling my pants
down and i keep saying stop
i can't put my pants down like he said
stop and he
tried to go up on my shirt and now you
grab me i said hey can you stop touching
me
stop touching me stop touching me please
stop touching me
and then and then i'm looking at him
digging this i'm like i'm going to take
a knife
and i'm sitting there but i can't move
because i'm whatever you call i think
shrimp or something
i can't move and it's like a very scary
situation
very situation so you try to like say
okay i'm gonna compromise and see just
what this person's gonna do
and then i said okay well okay okay okay
i'll do it i'll do it i'll do it because
i don't want no problem i'll do it
okay okay and say okay you know what let
me get up and go get
another uh another cover so i can cover
us up and then somebody
got having to walk back and say you okay
and i said no he's trying to
say let me help you up and don't do back
off of her
i was going away because i if he didn't
i think he he would have
from kept um proceeding to
do what he wanted to do to me so yeah
being dirty on your psycho period you
got to stop tissue in your panties
because you have no tampons to put on
like as now i'm using i'm using a paper
towel between my legs
you know to
well because i don't know what women's
center and that's this is very
embarrassing
to be as a woman to say you might
find a paper towel on the ground and
stick between your legs so you're
bleeding
really really bad and you have no
tapping them as a woman
but where do i turn to where do i go
that's going to do nothing
i learned that it's about drugs and
i don't think it's about drugs and self
and so i was like i want to i want i
want to get i want help so bad i want to
be off the streets
a women's shelter whatever whatever
somebody help me with
but i just said i just don't want to be
on this
i don't know but i mean you can't be
picky with somebody helping you out
you just have to be more cautious but
man
it's going to be in getting inside
somewhere safe
brielle i'll set you up for at least a
place to stay and some food
okay and maybe we can get you somewhere
because you could skate
you know women's shelter or something
like that yeah have you been to some of
the shelters for
for women i've never been into into the
um women's shelter i see them
and then when i asked some ladies he
said okay well they're helping people
i don't know where to go someone said
okay since you have
epilepsy and severe brain trauma they
start not helping
people like that and then they said okay
well where are you gonna be i'm gonna
come back
and she haven't came back since and i
really don't want to
be over because i'm very scared
all right well we'll try again